Now our suburban scene was quaint, but it was rather static. Let's add a second
interface to add some motion. The moveable interface has a method move, and we
give the number of seconds for the simulated motion. Now, cars are moveable,
our car class implements two interfaces, drawable, and movable. let's see how
that start. The car class now needs to implement the methods of both the
drawable and the movable interface. Here is the draw method that we've always
had, here is the move method we'll arbitrarily say that these cars moves at 10
pixel per second. And each of the components of the car is moved by that
amount. What's it look like? When you run the program, you can see this car
here moving. Later, we'll move the other cars as well, but for now please go
ahead and move Fido as well.